it's kelsey ballerini
[Applause]
would you stop it with that instagram
makeup what is going on who did that how
right person i'm trying to match your
energy here ugh head to toe
i'm i'm in head to toe
um i come off uh real strong i love it
have you ever come on strong like to
people
i um
yeah and i'm also just i'm really bad
around famous people i'm toning it down
really hard right now
um
yeah so i like for for example um you
know the cmas were last week i know when
you won
thank you
congratulations
[Applause]
okay right which leads me to this photo
which leads me to this photo the year
before see i don't really know miranda
somehow we haven't really crossed paths
a lot but i was at an after party and um
and i was nervous and her manager had
those really thin wine glasses they're
like super expensive and they're like
why the more expensive they are the
thinner they are it makes no sense and i
was talking to her and it hit my tooth
and it shattered in my mouth it busted
my lip i spit out like bloody shards of
glass in my hand in front of miranda and
then i was like well i can't leave
because then she's gonna think i just
eat glass and i don't do that on a
regular basis so it was a whole thing
and
i don't know we haven't really talked
since
it's fine this year was better this year
was better i remember once i went up to
clint eastwood um and i was like oh my
god i love you so much you're like my
favorite
and because that's me
and this is his response
[Music]
and it's disarming which is so clint
eastwood yeah and i still get as excited
about meeting someone as if i was
nowhere near this job so i much more
relate to you i think it's like holding
on to the magic of it all i do the
fangirl absolutely
well i am fan girling out over your new
book of poetry
um
i
have chills up and down my body right
now i've been reading it i heard you you
have doggie pages i heard you want you
like messy and i do oh you mentioned
that you want people to interact with it
right the whole book is about like
the messiness of growing up and the
things that are challenging and the
things that you overcome whether it's
traumas or your own thoughts or whatever
that's what makes you who you are which
ends up being beautiful and so i'm like
i i want i want it to look beautiful at
first and then i just wanted to become a
mess
i
love
this
by the way would you mind reading this
one oh god okay okay
okay what is this one i dog-eared it
but um okay
thank you i'm nervous i'm gonna like
stutter through it okay
it's called here with you
i swim in a bottomless sea of what ifs
an abyss to the brim of possibilities
bathing in ideologies flirting with
mystery-lined plots
submerged in deep blue of the haves and
have-nots
but not a single one of those
hypotheticals i've waded through are as
good is right here right now with you
[Applause]
that's a simple little one yeah
you recently uh posted this tick tock
with reese witherspoon that went like
wildfire um
how did this friendship yeah i love her
so much and what is it that you guys say
to each other about a honky tonk this is
actually funny so so we we chatted about
my book i've known reese for a couple
years now she's like kind of my big
sister people always said i i looked
like her and then i met her one day and
i aggressively was like oh my god i love
you and people say that we have the same
face and um
and i then she wasn't scared which is
good what a good vibe thank goodness
thank god but we we were talking about
the book and um i was can i do a tick
tock with you let's do that quote where
i say um you can take the girl out of
the honky tonk and you finish it and she
was like well what's what's the rest of
it i was like it's from sweet home
alabama melanie carmichael what do you
mean she forgot it that's hilarious i
didn't even know that
that's wrong
oh god when you when when you told her
it was her what did she say then i i
mean i think she just has a lot of words
in her head she's doing a lot of things
all the time so i have to say that one
of my favorite stories is the mailbox
story will you please tell it because
again this was another reason i thought
oh we could be friends okay i haven't
told this before and it's a little bit
illegal but um i that's why i like it
[Applause]
and i think i kind of fixed it way um
i'm such a people pleaser i never break
the law i never do any of that and um
long story short my friend from
knoxville told me that my childhood home
was on zillow and one day i got on there
and there were like five photos and the
last photo was the mailbox and i left
this house when i was 12. so that's the
house when my parents got divorced we
left the house right
very defining years and this mailbox is
like rusty and moldy and mossy but it
had ballerini down the side of it still
and i was and i'm doing this work in
therapy where i'm writing letters to my
younger self and i was like
it's mine i'm getting it so when i went
home to film the music video for my my
current song half of my hometown we
rapped
and i got my friends in the car
and i had an amazon mailbox in the back
and i went and i took the mailbox and i
put the box of the neo mailbox and now i
and now i have my my childhood
rusty moldy mailbox
and i and i write
and i write letters to my younger self
and it's really sweet all right you know
what can we um do a stands for stain
segment together i'm so excited about
this i know how passionate you are thank
you so much so excited okay okay
[Music]